hello everyone and welcome to the third
game of the noon chess classic finals
it's again magnus carlton vs hikaru
nakamura
rider hikaru has the white pieces here
in the first game of the second match
hikaru was able to bounce back and now
magnus needs a win to get back into the
match otherwise
hikaru will be able to force tie breaks
and now uh second game ended in a draw
it was a well a threefold repetition but
hikaru did get an age he wasn't
interested in trying to push for more
uh he rather drew that game and then
wanted to go for a win again
with the white pieces in this one and
thank you for all the constructive
comments regarding the the lighting
regarding the sound and everything like
i said i barely
managed to move yesterday and you know
started recording here but i am planning
to fix everything in the
well i hope in the coming weeks so uh i
do have some ideas of how to
you know uh tackle the sound issue i
know there's echo
it's not a lot but i myself am not a fan
of echo uh
so i i imagine most of you guys aren't
uh either
uh but i like i said i i will be
tackling that uh next week so
uh stay tuned for that hopefully
everything will get
fixed very quickly but getting back to
the game uh it's hikaru with the white
pieces again and he's looking for
his chances to force tie breaks so he
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have d5 by magnus c4 we have e6
and
knight to c3 and this one magnus doesn't
go for some
bishop to be for action rather he goes
for a6 this is the
novsky variation and it is well it is
not extremely rare but it is
much rarer than all the other uh
continuations mostly so here
we have cactus captures and bishop to f4
by hikar we have knight to f6
and now e3 preparing to develop the
light square bishop
bishop to d6 by magnus attacking blacks
bishop here and now
just the bishop captures md6 magnus
recaptures
bishop to d3 and now there are some
30-something games in the database where
black just castles here but magnus goes
bishop to g4
uh attacks he carries queen and it is
already as of move
uh 80 that we have a completely new game
so let's see how he car deals with it
he goes queen to b3 puts more pressure
on the center here but
also attacking that b7 pawn magnus just
continues development
knights the c6 and while you can capture
here
could be a could be a pretty dangerous
grab black will just castle then you can
start harassing the queen and the white
still
needs at least two moves to castle so
you're doing okay in the match you don't
want to
over complicate things for no reason so
here h3
pushing back uh magnus's bishop bishop
to h5
and now knight g to e2 getting ready to
castle
and here magnus does something uh very
interesting he gives up the bishop for
knight here
if this bishop if this knight comes to
f4 it's going to be an incredibly strong
piece
uh you're not really going to be able to
get rid of it that easily without
any maybe maneuvers night here the
captures or or by pushing g5 at some
point in the future
so magnus just eliminates it he car
captures with the other knight and
now magnus castles we have rook to c1
and now magnus knows that it could be an
issue because the c7 pawn is a bit weak
if this queen ever comes to c3 then it's
going to be
could be a problem so he just
immediately brings it back knight to d8
now he's gonna
uh improve his position with c6 also the
knight now defends the pawn
and the knight is coming to e6 sometimes
in the future so here
queen to a3 hikaru offers a queen trade
but now
queen back to d7 magnus not interested
he wants to look for his chances on the
king's side
uh we have castles by hikaru and now g6
uh we have knights the f4 finally the
knight reaches this very nice square
and rook to e8 by magnus simply
continuing development with bishop to c2
hikaru now wants to shift the knight
over to e5 uh
as uh so he freed the d3 square for the
knight
and now just c6 uh strengthening the
center here
uh we have knight to d3 as planned and
only now
knight to e6 by magnus with f4
now creating a beautiful central outpost
for this knight on e5
and here knight to g7 by magnus
and now while hikaru can immediately
bring the knight over to e5 he plays a
very very interesting move and
pushes f5 right away which looks like a
straight up pawn sacrifice but it's
really not because if you capture this
pawn
then we get knight to c5 with an attack
on the queen and also there's a double
attack on this knight now so hikaru
would be able to just capture here
and open up magnus's king side so magnus
instead after this
f5 move he just continues with g5
and now already things are getting very
interesting we have knight to e5 this is
now officially a monster night
uh maybe not right away because the
knights
still can challenge this night but it's
not easy for the moment the queen is on
d7 and
you don't really have the option of
challenging this knight from this square
uh it is possible however not
not quite right away so queen to c7
also might be freeing up the d7 square
for the knight and
now h4 hikaru wants to bust open the
position here but magnus says nope we're
keeping
it closed i'm just going to play g4 here
we have queen back to c3
and now comes knight g to h5 and now
these knights are getting uh well very
very close for comfort here
and hikaru plays queen to e1 now but
queen to e1 allows uh well
a very very interesting move here by
magnus so feel free to pause the video
here what would you do here you have
everything
nicely set up here but you know it's
required uh
to do something more so uh have at it
what would you
what would you play here while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
finding the uh well uh uh exchange
sacrifice with rook captures on e5 and
for also for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook captures an
e5
uh d captures his what he power played
and queen captures on e5 so now hikaru
is
up the exchange uh but uh those uh those
knights are
looking uh really really good and uh
well for the moment uh
the rook not really doing all that much
the bishop is helping out with the
defense of the f5 pawn yeah but hikaru
will definitely need to
to fight very hard to defend this so
here we have queen to c3
he offers a queen trade right away
magnus goes queen to g3
and hikaru goes back queen to e1 he
wants the trade queens but magnus of
course not interested he goes all the
way back
queen to d6 we have queen to f2
and now keeping around some very very
important squares
and now we have rooked e8 bringing the
final
uh attacker into the game we have rook
cetera d1
and now comes queen to e5 so what do you
play here is white here hikaru played
rook to d4
he grabs control of the fourth rank but
uh
well it's not it's not easy to hold this
while magnus could go for
queen captures on e3 uh i think this
would only help
white in the end the black is better
still here but hikaru would definitely
get fighting chances here
so instead uh we have just c5 pushing
hikaru's rook back and hikaru brings it
back to d2 so rook to d2
but now magnus just gets the knight into
the game knights the g3
and now the rook is under attack we look
after d1 putting more pressure on the d5
square
and now magnus not in a rush he just
improves the position with
king to f8 so what do you play here
hikaru tries to rook to d3 now not
allowing the magnets to capture on e3
any longer but now just knight after e4
uh and the queen is under attack here
and hikaru
has only one good move here pretty much
but even that's not enough it's uh
the best fighting chance he has probably
to just capture on d5 here
and then well both of the queens are now
under attack but magnus would capture on
b2 then bishop captures here for example
queen captures an f2 we trade king
captures knight captures on e4
and hikaru is of the exchange but the
problem is magnus would have this fork
here so after the king moves because
the king is in check knight c3 and now
one of the rooks
will fall uh you make any move with the
rook we're just gonna capture the knight
captures captures
and now rook captures on e3 magnus is up
two pawns
and this is a this is a winning endgame
so hikaru
doesn't like this his queen is under
attack so he just goes back
queen to e1 and now magnus goes queen to
f6
and now you really don't have a way of
defending against this it's a very very
uh straightforward idea he carl plays a
rook captures on d5 but now
queen captures an h4 with bishop capture
sunny for removing one of the attackers
but of course magnus does not recapture
we have to go in for the kill
he plays queen to h1 with check king to
f2
and now knight captures an e4 now this
comes with
check so king to e2 and now queen
captures on g2 with
check we have king to d3 by hikaru uh
but he was also in this position as he
carried played king to d3 on move 39
that hikaru nakamura resigned to the
game and with this uh
magnus bounces back in the match so now
the the match is a tie
and if the fourth game ends in a draw or
if magnus wins it
he wins the entire thing and if he car
wins then he can force tie breaks so
we'll see what happens
uh as hikaru just uh well he blundered
terribly here with
the white pieces but you know he can
still do some damage with the black
pieces here
so here you resign i'm just going to
show a fun line here for example c for
check you just start bringing the white
king closer into the position
queen c2 check king b4 and now we can
just you know
queen captures on b2 king a5 now we can
you know uh
harass the white king either way we want
uh one of the nicer ways is knight to d6
problem now is that the knight cannot be
captured because of this checkmate
and other than that well uh nice to see
four ideas like that
are coming and there is not much for you
to do here if you play some like queen
b4
or for a queen trade we're just gonna
play b6 with check
and now again what do you play here uh
if you capture this with the queen it's
really not a problem queen to a3 is
checkmate the knight covers b5
and if you don't do this uh well you
might do something like
king to a4 but then queen captures an a2
with
check queen a3 queen to c4 with check
queen to be for
now b5 with check and again not much for
you to do here if you go up the board
and queen to c7
so you have to go down the board and
then comes rook captures on e3
finally this rook joins the game with
with tempo
uh rook one to d3 and now we're gonna
capture captures captures and
now of course captures with check and
now black is up material here
and now even after king day two we can
even trade here
uh so you know being all sneaky about it
captures captures and now of course the
end game is completely winning
uh i'm showing this uh just because i
know how much you guys
enjoy this because i know a lot of you
guys will be uh but yes but how
how does he actually win well that's how
he actually wins
so that's the third game hope you guys
enjoyed it magnus winning he bounces
back in the match and we'll see what
happens in game four
so uh stay tuned for that uh i would
also like to thank calvin lancaster
dustin lackey
rob toy uh tom darylan and ricardo ross
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the new chess classic
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
tour so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day